standing by with Ben Simmons after a big
return thanks Ryan Ben I first have to
ask you how good did it feel to be back
here on this court playing at barklay
Center my
God amazing um just a blessing to be
back on the floor and play with my guys
and uh I'm glad we can get the win I
when you look at your stats you had 10
points eight rebounds 11 assists what
did you read in this game that allowed
you to find that Comfort level and to
Ute like that just Instinct I play I
play with my heart um and how I know how
to play the game so for me I just want
to find my guys and play the right way
you guys put up 147 points but it was
the defense that fied you guys jock told
me during pregame that this team can
score what allowed you guys to slow them
down containing them and how did that
get you guys going I think not getting
lost in the offense I think if we just
focus on defense offense is going to
come uh we have a lot of talented guys
on this roster um I'm trying to make it
easy for everybody all right
congratulations SP good to have you back
appreciate it back to you
Ryan